From Jamestown and Plymouth, their descendants grow across the landscape.
As more and more people cross the Atlantic: thousands, tens of thousands.
People with different backgrounds, different reasons for being here.
America becomes the place for everybody from everywhere.
Rolling the dice.
Coming together to create 13 colonies.
From Jamestown, agriculture spreads across the South.
Dirt farms transformed into sprawling plantations.
Irish, Germans and Swedes push back the frontier.
The Dutch bring commerce to a small island at the mouth of the Hudson River.
In time, it will be named New York.
The colonists are two inches taller and far healthier than those they left behind in Europe.
The Puritans average eight children.
And they are twice as likely to survive to adulthood.
They are 20 percent richer and pay only a quarter of the taxes of those in England.